diyelim ki arabanızın lastiğinde bir
tuhaflık hissettiniz bunun basıncı düştü
mü çıktı mı bunda bir tuhaflık var
dediniz o lastiğin basıncını nasıl
ölçersiniz veya evinizde bir koku
duydunuz doğalgaz kaçağından
şüpheleniyorsanız yetkilileri aradınız
geldiler tesisatınızda doğalgaz kaçağı
olup olmadığını nasıl kontrol ederler ne
kullanmaları gerekir veya uçakla
giderken pilotlar belli aralıklarla kaç
metre yükseklikte olduklarını söylerler
uçak yeryüzünden ne kadar yüksekte
olduğunu nasıl anlıyor bunların hepsinin
cevabı bu dersimizde bu dersimizde
basıncı ölçen aletleri öğreneceğiz ve
ilk olarak manometre ile başlayacağız
gençler Biz aslında basınç ölçen bir
alet öğrendik şimdiye kadar
derslerimizde o barometreyi atmosfer
basıncını açık hava basıncını ölçüyü
torelli deneyinde kullandığımız aletin
Ta kendisiydi şimdi kapalı bir kaptaki
basıncı ölçüyoruz açık hava basıncını
ölçmeye çalışmıyoruz ve biz buna
manometre ismini veriyoruz gördüğünüz
gibi arabalarımızın lastiğindeki basıncı
ölçmek istediğinizde bu subap kısmına
şöyle bir alet takıyorsunuz buradaki
göstergede Bu iç basıncın ne olduğunu
anlamaya çalışıyorsunuz bu alet bir
benzerini benzincilerde de görürsünüz
kablo gibi bir şeyi vardır getirirsiniz
lastiğe takarsınız oradaki ekranda
lastik basıncını görürsünüz ona göre
hava basarsınız veya yeteri kadar hava
varmış dersiniz arabanın lastiği kapalı
bir sistemdir kapalı bir kaptır
Dolayısıyla kapalı kap basıncını ölçtüğü
bu aletin ismi
manometrede de aynı şey var yangın
tüpleri kapalı sistemlerdir O iç basıncı
ölçmek için buradaki göstergeye
bakarsınız Çünkü burada da manometre
vardır manometre kullanırken Biz genelde
civa kullanıyoruz kapalı kap dediğim şey
şu cam tüp olarak düşünülürse burada gaz
var ve bu gazın basıncını ölçmek
istiyoruz bunun ucuna şöyle ince bir cam
tüp takıyoruz ve onu cıvayla
dolduruyoruz burası kapalı olabilir ya
da Burası açık olabilir Açık olursa P0
etkili olacak bunu biliyoruz kapalı
olursa açık hava basıncının bu sisteme
etki etmeyeceğini söyleyebiliriz ve şu
anki İşlediğim durumda Burası da tamamen
boşluk yani burada herhangi bir gaz yok
buraya bu gazı doldurduğunuz anda
Normalde eşit olacak olan CIA seviyeleri
arasında fark oluşur sebep E çünkü bu
gazın basıncı buradan civaya etki eder
Pascal prensibi yaparsak şuradan bir
seviye çekersek bu noktadaki basınçla bu
noktadaki basınç aynıdır Çünkü aynı
seviyede ve aynı cıvaya temas ediyorlar
E bu kırmızı noktada Gaz basıncı var
yukarıdan bu kırmızı noktada şu CIA
sütununun ağırlığından kaynaklanan bir
basınç var buradaki Gaz basıncı civa
tarafından Pascal prensibi gereği Aynen
buraya aktarılmıştır ve yukarıdan gelen
civanın H dgsi ile p gaz birbirini
dengelemiş O yüzden ben burada Nasıl bir
eşitlik yazarım Gaz basıncı eşittir h
derinlikli d Öz kütleli civanın basıncı
buradaki H dediğim şey mesela 20 cm
olarak oluştu civa seviyesi farkı buysa
sen buradaki H yerine 20 cm yazarsın dgi
temsilen de civa kullandığımız için
kimyadaki civa sembolünü kullanırız 20
cm civa basıncı vardır Bu p gazın deriz
bu gazın basıncı daha fazla olsaydı
Buradan daha şiddetli bastırsın o zaman
buradaki civayı daha çok yükseltecek
yani H artacaktı bu 20 dediğim sayı
belki 30 olacaktı o zaman da diyecektin
ki ha bu yeni gazın basıncı 30 cm cvad
diyecektin bu gazın basıncı ile ilgili
bana Fikri seviyeler arasındaki mesafe
veriyor burası kapalı olmak zorunda
değil açık uçlu manometreler imiz de var
var açık hava basıncı da dışarıdan etki
edebilir yine bir cıva seviyesi farkı
oluşmuş aynı şekilde şuradan seviyemi
çekersem bu noktadaki basınçla bu
noktadaki basınç eşittir soldaki kırmızı
noktaya Tabii ki yukarıdan p gaz etki
ediyor Sağdaki kırmızı noktaya civa
sütununun basıncı etki ediyor Bir de
yukarıdan açık hava basıncı etki ediyor
Dolayısıyla denklemde ufak bir
değişiklik olacak p gaz eş hdg lik cıva
sütunu artı yukarıdan etki eden P0 açık
hava basıncı şimdi bu deniz seviyesinde
ise 0 celsa ise açık hava basıncını 76
cm civa olarak kabul edebiliriz P0
yerine gelirsin Burada 76 cm cıva
yazarsın buradaki Mesafeyi de tamamen
sallıyorum 10 cm olarak ölçtün o zaman
hdgd H yerine 10 cm yazarsın DG zaten
civayı temsil ediyor Dolayısıyla buraya
bir de 10 cm CIA yazarsın ikisinin
toplamı gaz basıncıdır yani gazın
basıncı 86 cm cadır dersin Eğer
manometrenin işin içerisine açık hava
basıncın da dahil edip p gazı öyle
düşünmen gerekir hocam açık hava basıncı
atmosfer basıncı buradaki gazdan daha
büyük basınca sahip olamaz mı Tabii ki
ol olabilir Ama o zaman kim Galip
gelecektir Tabii ki atmosfer basıncı
açık hava basıncı Galip gelecektir cıva
seviyeleri değişecektir bu sefer sağdan
bastırırsın solu yükseltirsin ama oturup
Böyle olunca da şöyle oluyormuş diye
ezber yapmayacağız Tabii ki yani bu
durumu da kendiniz ben anlatmasam bile
çıkarabilmesi şöyle bir seviye
çekersiniz bu noktadaki basınçla bu
noktadaki basınç eşittir dersiniz
soldaki sarı noktada ne vardır
dediğimizde buradan p gaz etki ediyor
dersiniz artı bakın şurada bir CIA
sütunu var diyelim ki 10 cm olsun o
zaman bu sarı noktada şu an p gaz + 10 C
civalı bir basınç var eşittir Sağdaki
sarı nokta Çünkü aynı seviyeden aynı
civadra basıncı zaten ona da 76 cm civa
derseniz p gazın buradan 66 cm cıva
olması gerektiğini anlarsınız yani
yaptığımız bir şey yok seviye çekiyoruz
noktaların basınçlarını birbirine
eşitliyor bazen de manometrenin ucu
kapalı olduğu halde bu boşluk Dediğim
yerde başka bir Gaz olabilir açık hava
basıncının olmasıyla aynı durumdur
hiçbir fark yok yine Seviyeni çekersin
bu noktadaki basınçla bu noktadaki
basınç eşittir dersin soldaki kırmızı
noktada x gazının basıncı var Sağdaki
kırmızı noktada bu kadarlık civa sütunu
artı şuradan gelen y gazının basıncı var
yani hdg + py yazarsın gayet Basit
şekilde gördüğünüz u şeklindeki boru bir
manometrede olması şart değil sağ
taraftaki kısım kapalı ucuna Bir hortum
bağlanmış ve bir şırıngaya bağlanmış
şırınganın içerisinde ortamdaki hava var
şu an sol taraftaki Borunun ucu ise açık
Yani buradan açık hava basıncı etki
ediyor Şimdi biz bu şırıngayı takmadan
önce buradaki Borunun ucu da açık olduğu
için Aslında sol taraftaki boruda da sağ
taraftaki boruda da açık hava basıncı
kadar hava basıncı var diyebiliriz
Burada da boyalı bir sıvımız var civa
olup olmadığından emin değilim şahsen
Ama fark etmez D yerine başka bir sayı
yazarsın civanın öz kütlesi değil de
başka bir şey üzerinden hesap yaparsın
şimdi bakın buradaki şırıngayla
oynayarak hacmi küçülterek Ya da
büyüterek ben basıncı değiştiririm
basınç değiştiğinde de bu sıvının
seviyeleri arasındaki farkın değiştiğini
görürüm dikkat edin şırıngayı itiyor
Dolayısıyla buradaki hacmi küçültüyor
basıncı arttırıyor basınç arttığı için
civalar seviyeleri arasında bir fark
oluşuyor Mesela şu an durdurduk Biz
şırıngayı iterek şu cam tüpün
içerisindeki basıncı arttırmış olduk
buradan bir seviye çektiğimde bu
noktanın basıncıyla bu noktanın basıncı
birbirine eşit Sağdaki sütunda p gaz var
p gaz yazdım soldaki sütunda şu kadarlık
sıvının yüksekliğinden kaynaklanan bir
basınç var hdg var Artı Burası açık
olduğu için buradan da bir P0 etki
ediyor Art P0 var diyebiliriz İşte bu
bizim basınç denklem imiz p 0'ın
değerini biliyoruz arada bir cetvel var
gördüğünüz gibi buradan H mesafesini
seviyeler arasındaki farkı ölçebilir e
sıvının öz kütlesi ve Yer çekimini de
biliyorum yerine yazdığımda gazın
basıncının ne olduğunu anlayabilirim
şimdi bakın boruyu buradan çıkartıyor
Dolayısıyla sağ tarafta da açık hava
basıncı var sol tarafta da açık hava
basıncı var seviyeler Hemen eşitlendi
Çünkü buradan da açık hava etki ediyor
Buradan da açık hava etki ediyor İkisi
birbirini götürürse O zaman kimse Galip
gelmiyor eşit seviyede kalıyoruz
diyebiliriz buradaki Borunun ucu da açık
buradaki Borunun ucu da açık tekrar
şırıngayı taktı Az önce sıkıştırmış tım
Dolayısıyla basıncı arttırıp buradan
bastırabilmek şimdi tam tersini
yapacağız şırıngayı geri çekiyoruz
buradaki hacmi arttırıyoruz hacmi
arttırdığımız için sağ taraftan gelen
gaz basıncını şırınganın içindeki gaz
basıncını azaltmış oldum Dolayısıyla
buradan etki eden açık hava basıncı daha
baskın hale geldi ve bu sefer sütun sağ
tarafta yükseldi yine nasıl hesap kitap
yapacağız yani şu şırınganın içerisinde
ne kadar basınç var dediğimde seviyeyi
çekersin bu pembe noktayla bu pembe
noktayı eşitlensin P0 = p gaz ı şu
kadarlık sıvının basıncı diyebiliriz
benzer şekilde yine
manometrenin zaman seviye farkı oluşuyor
Çünkü basıncı arttırıyor ortama yeni gaz
moleküllere aktarıyor bıraktığı anda
Sağdaki Borunun ucu da açık soldaki
Borunun da açık İki taraftan aynı açık
hava basıncı etki ettiği için seviye
farkı oluşmuyor şimdi bakın ucuna bir
balon takıyor balonun içerisindeki
basınçtan dolayı yine sol taraftan
baskın olduğunu söyleyebiliriz balonu
çıkarttı İki taraftan açık hava etki
ediyor tekrar aynı seviyeye geldiler cam
bir tüpe bağladı bizim borumuz ve sıcak
bir suya koydu Sıcak suya koyarsa cam
tüpün içerisindeki havayı ısıtmış
olursun basıncını arttırırsın bakın
nasıl seviye farkı oluşuyor şimdi onu
alıyor tekrar soğuk suya koyuyor soğuk
suya koyduğunda tekrar basıncı azalttığı
için tekrar seviyeler Eski yerine
geliyorlar diyebiliriz manometre tam
olarak böyle çalışır açık hava
basıncının P0 olduğu ortamda düşey
kesiti verilen manometre içindeki gaz ve
cıva ile şekildeki gibi dengededir Buna
göre sistemde sadece gazın sıcaklığının
artması sağlanırsa yargılarından
hangileri doğru olur diye sormuş şimdi
şu anki denge durumunu bir incelememiz
lazım kapalı bir kabımız var içerisinde
gaz var civam var bu bir manometre açık
uçlu bir manometre yukarıdan açık hava
basıncı etki ediyor buradan seviyemi
çektim buradaki basınçla buradaki basınç
eşit buradan Gaz basıncı etki ediyor p
gaz eşittir Bu kırmızı noktanın üstünde
ne var hdg var Artı Bir de P0 var
denklem Bu sadece gazın sıcaklığını
arttırıyoruz niye sadece gaz diye
özellikle belirtiyoruz civada ısınıyor
genleşiyor falan o toplara girmemek için
ya da ne bileyim kapta genleşebilir
bulunduğu kabın hacmi bu bizim için
sabit kap büyümüyor küçülmüyor o zaman
sıcaklığı arttırdığımız basıncı artar
diyebiliriz buradaki p gaz arttı P0
zaten sabit bunu değiştirme gücümüz Eğer
deney ortamını değiştirmiyorsa yok
civanın öz kütlesi değişmiyor yerçekim
ivmesi değişmiyor mecburen civanın
seviyeleri arasındaki fark artacaktır
yani gaz soldan bastıracak burayı itecek
civayı sıkıştıramazsın
yeni hımı bu iki seviye arasındaki şu
mesafe olacaktır H üssü diyelim buna H
üssü haan daha büyüktür bu birinci
öncülü en sona bırakıyorum Çünkü burada
bazı kafalara takılan şeyler oluyor
Onları gidermek için en son biri
konuşacağım ve o Soru işaretlerini de
gidereceğiz H mesafesi artar Evet şimdi
söyledim K noktasındaki toplam basınç
artar K noktası en dipte bir nokta
toplam basınçtan kastımız Allah ne
verdiyse işte açık hava basıncı civanın
basıncı falan filan Şimdi ben bu K
noktasındaki basıncı iki yerden
düşünebilirim sağındaki cam borudan
düşünebilirim solundaki cam borudan
Dolayısıyla gazdan düşünebilirim biz bu
arkadaşı sağ taraftan düşünsek şu
kısımdan ne vardı Bunun üzerinde sağ
tarafta p P0 vardı artı bir de orada CIA
yüksekliği var k'ya kadar baktığım için
komple şu sütunu almam lazım yükseklik
olarak p CIA var biz bu sistemde gazı
ısıttığımızda Sağdaki sütun Yukarı çıktı
P0 değişmedi ama civanın yüksekliği
arttığı için H dgn hı arttığı için K
noktasındaki toplam basınç arttı O
yüzden 3'e de doğru demeliyim Şimdi
hemen bazılarınızın Aklındaki Soru
işaretlerini hissedebiliyorum O yüzden
birinci Öncül geliyorum gazın hacmi
büyüdüğünden basıncı azalır Hocam siz
dediniz ki biz burada sıcaklığı
arttırıyoruz sıcaklığı arttırdığımız
için basınç artar dediniz ama burada CIA
seviyesinin aşağı indiğini biliyoruz
Dolayısıyla buradaki gazın kapladığı
hacim artıyor aslında v'de bir artış var
yani pvn RT de tamam bu sabit bu sabit
sıcaklık arttı ama belki hacim de arttı
buradaki civanın alçalmasına dolayı
oluşan hacim artışını niye dikkate
almıyorsunuz direkt basınç artar diye
yapıştırdın Şimdi öncelikle zaten
Şuradaki kabın hacmi ile Şuradaki cam
Borunun hacmi kıyaslandığında cam
borular çok ince yapıldığı için bu ihmal
edilir Dolayısıyla Biz burada gazın
hacmi dediğimizde şu kabı baz alırız
kendimize bunda herhangi bir değişiklik
olmadığı için hacim sabit bittir diye
düşünebilirim ama öyle olmasa bile az
önceki deneyi izledik sıcak bir suya
soktuğumuzda civa seviyeleri arasında
fark oluştu Yani basıncı arttırmış
buradaki civa seviyesi aşağı indi hacim
de artıyor o zaman basıncı artıram
biliriz demedik ki zaten ben az önce ne
dedim K noktasındaki toplam basınç
artacak dedim K noktasındaki toplam
basınç civa seviyesi azalıp civanın
basıncı azalmasına rağmen artıyorsa
Demek ki Gaz basıncı daha çok artmalı
gazın basıncın arttığından hiçbir
şüphemiz yok o yüzden birinci öncülü
doğru kabul edemem Sorumun cevabı 2 ve
3'tür gençler açık hava basıncının P0
olduğu bir ortamda Kapalı uçlu
manometrenin ucuna esneklik direnci
önemsiz esnek çocuk balonu takılmış ve
civa şekildeki gibi dengede kalmıştır
Buna göre açık hava basıncı Gaz basıncı
ve x gazının basıncı arasındaki ilişkiyi
yazınız esneklik direnci ihmal edilmiş
bir balonumu var balon burada böyle
dengede kalıyorsa O zaman ne yazabiliriz
önceki dersimizde konuşmuştuk biz bunu
dışarıdan etki eden açık hava basıncıyla
içerideki balonun içerisindeki Gaz
basıncı birbirine eşittir Çünkü eşitlik
olmasaydı Bu balon ya küçülür dü ya da
büyür dü böyle kalıyorsa P0 = p gazdır
peki Peki manometre incelendiğinde x
gazıyla Bu balon içerisindeki gaz
arasında nasıl bir ilişki kurabilirim
Pascal yaparım şuradan seviyemi çekerim
bu noktadaki basınçla bu noktadaki
basınç eşittir sağ taraftan x gazı
bastırıyor sol tarafta şuradan balonun
içerisindeki gaz bastırıyor E bir de bu
kadarlık civanın basıncı var yani
denklemin p gaz + civanın basıncı hdg =
px p gazı bir şeyle topluyorum pxi elde
ediyorum demek ki x gazının basıncı
balonun içerisindeki gazın basıncından
daha büyükmüş o zaman Sorumun cevabı ne
olur x büyk balon O da eşittir P0 Şimdi
size başka bir şey sorayım soruyu
Hallettik Ama aklıma geldi konuşalım ben
buradaki balonu Buradan çıkarsam civa
seviyesinde bir değişiklik olur mu ha
hocam bu balonu çıkartırsanız civalar
hemen eşitlenir Hayır eşitlenme atmosfer
basıncı Neyse Gaz basıncı da o değil mi
Evet o E o zaman bu burada olmasa ne
değişir ki yine buradan p gaz yerine bu
sefer atmosfer basıncı açık hava basıncı
etki edecek Burada p gaz yerine P0
yazsam bu denklemde bir şey değişecek mi
Hayır Bunlar eşit hiçbir şey
değişmeyecek Dolayısıyla civa seviyesi o
balon Olmasaydı da korunur Şimdi gelelim
dersin başında konuşt tuğumuz başka bir
soruya uçaklar ne kadar yüksekte
olduğunu nasıl anlıyor bunun için
Uçaklarda basıncı ölçen bir alet bulunur
Altimetre deriz buna altimetrenin altisi
İngilizcedeki yükseklikten geliyor metre
zaten bir ölçü aleti olduğunu bana
anlatıyor yükseklik ölçen alet bunun
basınçla ne ilgisi olabilir ya da hangi
tür basınçla ilişkisi olabilir e uçak
havada olduğuna göre etrafında nasıl bir
basınçla muhatap oluyor Tabii ki açık
hava basıncıyla atmosfer basıncıyla
muhatap oluyor ve biz daha önce öğrendik
ki yeryüzünden uzaklaştıkça Dağlara
Tepelere çıktıkça yükseldikçe açık hava
basıncı azalır Çünkü üstümüzdeki
atmosfer miktarı azalır kütle çekim
etkisinden dolayı yeryüzünde atmosfer
daha sıktır yukarı çıktıkça seyrekleşir
Dolayısıyla uçak yeryüzündeyken pistte
yken üzerinde yüksek basınç var yüksek
açık hava basıncı var yukarıya çıktıkça
alçak hava basıncı var işte içindeki
sensörler bunu ölçüyorlar Altimetre
dediğimiz bu Sağdaki arkadaş basınca
göre değişip o basıncı yüksekliğe
çevirir Peki bunu nasıl yapar uçağın
dışında şurada bir sensör var bir giriş
var açık hava basıncını algılıyor O
basıncın çokluğuna azlığına göre
nanometre benzeri bir civa hareketi
gözlemliyoruz içerideki Bu açık hava
basıncı miktarı artınca burayı sol
tarafı sıkıştırıyor bu çarklar ona göre
hareket edip göstergedeki ibreleri
hareket ettiriyor basınç azaldığında bu
tekrar böyle genişliyor basınç etkisi
azaldığı için çarklar ona göre
dönüyorlar bu göstergeler de ona göre
hareket ediyorlar tamamen basıncın
mekaniğe dönüştürülmüş hali yani
Altimetre açık hava basıncından Mekanik
bir hesaplama yapıyor aslında kendince
ve sana yüksekliği söylüyor tamamen
sallıyorum deniz seviyesinde açık hava
basıncı 76 cm civa yukarılara çıktıkça
bu azalıyor doğrusal bir Azal değil
tabii ki ama tamamen sallıyorum diyelim
ki her 1 kilometrede 1 cmlik bir azalma
var bizim
barometrenin ölçersin ne yorum yaparsın
ha Bizim
barometreli ola o zaman 10 cm 10 kreye
karşılık gelir Yani biz yeryüzünden
10.000 metre yukarıdaydı bu bunu uçaklar
kullanabildiği gibi Dağcılar da
kullanabiliyorlar kaç metreye
tırmandığını ölçüyorlar diğer ölçü
aletimiz basınç ölçen aletimiz batimetre
Bu da denizin altında kullanılan alet
batmaktan aklınıza gelsin denizaltılar
kullanır Dalgıçlar kullanır bunun
basınçla ne ilgisi var E tabii ki hdg
ile ilgisi var bu arkadaş da üzerindeki
sıvı basıncından H hakkında yorum
yapabiliyor yani derinlik hakkında
sıvının öz kütlesi belli yer çekim
ivmesi belliyse basıncı sensörün de
ölçtüğünde H hakkında yorum yapmış
oluruz yine günlük hayata bağlayacağım
bir soru Dalgıçlar Neden belli
derinliklerde zaman geçirmeden Su
yüzeyine çıkmazlar Örneğin bu dalış
rekorları videolarını izlerseniz Hadi
hoşça kalın Ben gidiyorum deyip böyle
komple dalmıyor işte 10 metre iniyor
orada biraz bekliyor bir 10 metre daha
iniyor orada biraz daha bekliyor çünkü
vücudunun o dış basınca dış sıvı
basıncına uyum sağlaması gerekiyor Bu
yukarı çıkarken daha da uyumlu hale
geliyor yukarı birden çıkarsak Vurgun
dediğimiz olay yaşayabiliyoruz 100
metreye indin 90'a çıkıyorsun orada
bekliyorsun 80'e çıkıyorsun orada
bekliyorsun 70'e çıkıyorsun orada
bekliyorsun vücudunu uyumlu hale
getiriyorsun dış basınca Çünkü bizim
kanımızda yanlış hatırlamıyorsam azot
gazı olması lazım basınç etkisiyle
çözünmüş durumda sen şimdi 100 metreden
yukarıya hiç beklemeden çıkarsan
dışarıdaki sıvı basıncı Çok şiddetli bir
şekilde azalacağı için bu Kandaki
çözünmüş azot hızlı bir şekilde gaza
dönüşür kan damarlarında azot gazı
dolaşmaya başlar Bu da Vurgun dediğimiz
dalgıçların ölmesine bile sebebiyet
verebilecek olaya sebep olur Böylece
basınç ölçen ölçü aletlerini bitirmiş
olduk şimdi başka sorularla
karşınızdayım o sorular için önce bir
şeyler izleyelim bakın burada bir buz
kütlemiz var bu buz kütlemizi bir bakır
tel geçirip İki taraftan tuğlalar asmış
Dolayısıyla bu buz kütlesine şu an
tuğlaların ağırlığın dolayı bakır tel
vasıtasıyla bir basınç uyguluyoruz Hem
de bayağı bir basınç uyguluyoruz çünkü
hem tuğlalar ağır hem de bakır tel
incecik yani kuvvet büyük alan küçük
basınç devasa yeterince beklerseniz ki
video % 18800 hızlandırılmış durumda
buradaki bakır telin yavaş yavaş buz
kütlesinin içine girdiğini yani o
basıncın olduğu yerde buzu erittiğini ve
en sonunda da erite erite düşeceğini
göreceksiniz bakın git gide tuğlalar
alçalıyor Çünkü o bakır tel şu an buzun
içerisine girdi bu tuhaf bir şey değil
hocam eriyor işte o da aşağıya iniyor
tuhaf ol olan şey şu tuğlalar bir yere
düşsün ve Buz kütlesini tekrar
inceleyelim gördüğünüz gibi iyice
aşağıya indi ve en sonunda aşağıya düştü
Buz kütlesi tek parça Buz kütlesi ikiye
yarılmadı o bakır telin geçtiği yerler
tekrar donmuş Bu nasıl mümkün burada ne
yaşandı veya karlı yollarda arabaların
geçtiği yerlerde neden daha az Kar
vardır Çünkü basınç hal değişimini
etkiler basınç buzun erimesini
kolaylaştırır arabaların geçtiği yerde
sürekli bir basınç etkisi olduğu için
oradaki kar buz eriyor ama arabaların
geçmediği yol kenarlarında o kar duruyor
kitaplarda daha akademik cümleler
görürsünüz onu da söylememiz lazım
basınç buzun erime noktasını düşürür
gençler Yani normalde sizin buz
dediğiniz şey 0 celciusa geldiğinde
eriyorsa -5 celsus da erir sırf üzerine
bir basınç uygulanıyor diye erime
noktasını düşürür E hocam bu erimeyi
kolaylaştırmak ki bu zorlaştırır
diyebilirsiniz Aslında çelişkili gibi
dursa da hiçbir çelişki yok mesela şu an
ortamda kar var ortamda buz var erimiyor
neden erimiyor Çünkü erimesi için ortam
sıcaklığının 0 celsus olması lazım ki
erime noktasına ulaşsın buz Şimdi senin
havan -5 celsus bu hava sıcaklığı
ortamdaki buzun Sıcaklığı da Dolayısıyla
bu o buz erir mi erimez Hava çok soğuk
Çünkü E ben buzu ısıtamıyorum basınç
sayesinde 0 celciusa erimesi gereken
erime noktasını -5 celciusa getiririm
yani Havayı oraya çıkartamıyorum buzu
buraya getiririm Hava -5 celus buz -5 de
eriyebilir hale geldi e buz Eridi basınç
buzun erimesini kolaylaştırır Çünkü
basınç buzun erime noktasını düşürür
çocukken kart topu Oynamışsın ZD kart
topunu sıktığınızda eliniz ıslanır Yani
sıktığınız yerler eriyor Aslında
ıslaklık oradan geliyor Peki bizim
deneyimiz de ne oldu şimdi kolay
düşünmek adına bu ortamdaki hava
sıcaklığını Ben -5 celsus hayal etmek
istiyorum buradaki Buz kütlesi de 0
celciusa gelmesi lazım erimesi için
şimdi hava -5 Dolayısıyla burada
yeterince beklemiş olan buz da -5
celciusa bu buz erimez Çünkü sıfıra
ulaşması lazım ya hava ısınacak ya da
basınç uygulayacağız İşte buradaki bakır
tel bulunduğu yere basınç uyguluyor
bulunduğu yerde erime noktasını
düşürüyor atıyorum -5 yapıyor hava -5 mi
Evet buz -5 mi Evet bakır telin
bulunduğu yerde erime noktası -5 düştü
mü Evet E o zaman buz erimeye başladı O
yüzden bu bakır tel erite erite erite
geliyor ve en sonunda bu tuğlalar yere
düşüyor şekilde gördüğünüz gibi asıl
problem E tamam orayı erittik orayı
kestik neden elimde iki tane buz Parçası
yok Nasıl yine bu arkadaş tek parça oldu
orası yine niye dondu Çünkü basınç
olmazsa o bakır tel orada olmazsa -5
düşmüş olan erime noktası tekrar s0a
gelir hava Hala -5 buz hala -5 celsa ve
buz artık sıfırda eriyebilir sda
eriyebilen adam - 5'te isse donması
lazım O yüzden o bakır telin geçtiği her
yer tekrar donuyor tuğlalar bağımsız
hale geldiğinde buzdan O yüzden buz hala
tek parça basınç buzun erime noktasını
düşürür Şimdi burada hemen bir uyarı
yapmam gerekiyor buz özel bir duruma
sahip silisyum gibi germanyum gibi
bizmut gibi antimon gibi yani Bu
saydığım maddeler ve buz basınca maruz
kaldıklarında erime noktalarını
düşürüyorlar basınç buzun erimesini
kolaylaştırıyor ama bir demir bir bakır
bir Kalay böyle maddelerin erime noktası
basınç sayesi
yükseliyor gençler günlük hayatta Zaten
bizmut antimon germanyum falan
görmediğiniz için basınç buz ilişkisi
kendine Hastır olarak öğrenebilirsiniz
geri kalan her şeyde basınç artarsa
erime noktası yükselir yani atıyorum
demirin erimesi basınçla zorlaşır Neden
böyle Çünkü su ve buz ilişkisi kendine
az Yani bir katının sıvısında yüzdüğü
çok gördüğümüz bir şey değil buzu suya
attığımızda katı yüzüyor ama siz sıvı
demirin içine katı Demir attığınızda
katı Demir batar buzun öz kütlesi 0.9 gr
B cm küken suyun öz kütlesi 1'dir katı
demirin öz kütlesi 7,8 Ken sıvı demiri
bilmiyorum tamamen sallıyorum ama
battığı için sıvı Demir daha küçük
olmalı 7'dir d = n / v'den düşünürsem
erisek de donsak da madde miktarımız
aynı kütle değişmez Eğer benim öz kütlem
arttıysa hacmimi demektir yani ben bu
buzu erittiğim de hacmi küçülüyor çünkü
başka türlü 0.9 olan öz kütlesi sıvı
hale geçtiğinde 1'e çıkamaz hacminin
küçülmesi lazım E basınç da zaten hacmi
küçültmeye yönelik bir işlem değil midir
dışarıdan basınç etki ediyor küçül diye
zorluyor seni e zaten bu adam erirken
küçülmeye çalışıyor yardımcı oluyor yani
basınç O yüzden basınç buzun erimesini
kolaylaştırıyor ama diğer maddeler Bunun
tam tersi katı demirin öz kütlesi 7.8
sıvı demiri 7 sıvı demiri salladım ama
daha küçük yani katı Demir erirken sıvı
hale geçerken Öz kütlesinin azalması
lazım kütle sabit olduğuna göre hacminin
artması lazım yani katı Demir
erittiğiniz de hacmi büyüyor E sen ona
basınç uyguluyorsun adam büyümeye
çalışıyor Sen diyorsun ki hayır
büyümeyecek basınç demirin erimesini
zorlaştırır ya da akademik olarak
söylersek basınç demirin Er noktasını
yükseltir bu farkları bilmeniz lazım
tekrar buza geri dönersek yaz ayı
olmasına rağmen erges dağının
tepelerinde neden kar var niye tepelerde
oluyor bu Everest niye sürekli Karlı
Yazın da çıkıyorlar kışın da çıkıyorlar
hep kar var everest'te Çünkü burası çok
yüksek çok yüksek olduğu için açık hava
basıncı az Basınç azsa erime zorlaşır O
yüzden buradaki kar erimiyor O yüzden
dağlar tepeler Everest sürekli karlılar
Şimdi gelelim kaynamaya düdüklü
tencereler normal tencerelere göre
yemekleri çok daha kısa sürede
pişiriyorlar bunun sebebi ne düdüklü
tencerenin normal bir tencereden farkı
ne Tabii ki basınç tamamen kapalı bir
sistem şurada bir valfi var bir düdük
kısmı var oradan kontrollü bir şekilde
gaz çıkışı yapabilir ama Orayı da
kapatırsan içeride kaynattığını hep
İçeride kalır Bu da dışarıdan etki eden
basıncın sürekli artması demek yani su
ısındıkça buharlaşma devam ettikçe buhar
içeride kaldığı için sıvının üzerindeki
basınç sürekli artıyor Ee hocam Ne olmuş
basınç artıyorsa basınç artarsa kaynama
zorlaşır Bu da çok soru
çözdürebilirim zorlaştırır peki bunun
yemeği daha kısa sürede pişirme le Ne
ilgisi var bakın sizinle ısı ve sıcaklık
işledik Eğer bir madde hal
değiştiriyorsa sıcaklığını
değiştiremezsiniz Normal bir su Hayal
edelim düdüklü tencereyi unutun
ısıtırsın ısıtırsın ısıtırsın 100
celciusa geldiğinde kaynamaya başlar
deniz seviyesinde siniz Bundan sonra ne
kadar Isı enerjisi verirsen ver buradaki
su tamamen bitene kadar o su hep 100
celsus Adır sıcaklığı değişmez Çünkü hal
değiştiriyor Çünkü kaynıyor E bu suyun
içerisinde senin bir yemeğin varsa bu
bir yemekse şu an Senin yemeğin 100 cusa
pişiyor demektir daha fazla
arttıramıyorum
düdüklü tencereye koyduğun zaman düdüklü
tenceredeki dış basınç sürekli artacağı
için içerideki buhar bir yere kaçamadı
için kaynama zorlaşır Yani sen bunu
alttan yaktın tencereyi ısıtıyorsun 90
celsus oldu kaynama yok 95 oldu kaynama
yok 100 oldu kaynama yine yok çünkü
kaynamayı zorlaştırdı basınç 105 oldu
kaynama yok işte atıyorum 120 oldu
kaynama başlıyor ha buradan sonra
değişmese bile artık Bizim yemeğimiz 120
celsus da pişiyor bu basınç olayları
olmasaydı yani düdüklü tencere olmasaydı
yemeğim 100 celsus da pişiyo şimdi 120
celsius da pişiyor daha yüksek
sıcaklıkta pişiyorsa Tabii ki daha çabuk
pişer basınç suyun kaynamasını
zorlaştırır akademik dille ifade edersek
basınç suyun kaynama noktasını yükseltir
100'lük adamı 120 yapar Peki niye
zorlaştırıyor hocam anladık basınç var
ama niye zorlaştırıyor kaynama dediğiniz
şey şurada oluşan gaz kabarcıklarının
yükselip burada patlaması olayı değil mi
böyle fokur fokur kaynama dediğimiz şey
budur içeride gaz kabarcıkları oluşuyor
ve suyun dışına çıkıyor bu gaz
kabarcığının oluşabilmesi lazım sen
Alttan Bunu ısıttığın da bunu bir balon
gibi düşün sıcaklığını arttırıyordu
git gide büyüyor hacmi artıyor Ama sen
dışarıdan etki eden basıncı arttırırsan
bu sıvı bu basıncı Pascal yüzünden aynen
bu baloncuğa aktarırsak bu balonun
dışındaki basınç artmış olur dıştan
gelen basıncı yenmek için içteki gazın
basıncını daha da arttırmanız daha da
çok sıcaklığını
arttırmanın yeteri kadar büyüyebilmesi
için artık 100 derecelik sıcaklık yetmez
Çünkü şunu da yenmel isin artık yeterli
hacme ulaşmak için 120'ye çıkarman
gerekir Yani aslında kaynama dediğimiz
olayda buradaki baloncuğun iç basıncı
sıvının dışındaki o buharda dış basıncı
da yenmeye çalışıyor bu arkadaş arttıkça
mecburen bunun iç basıncını da
arttırmalıyız mecburen sıcaklığını da
arttırmalıyız basınç kaynamayı
zorlaştırıyorsa basıncın azlığı da
kaynamayı kolaylaştırır deniz
seviyesinde belli bir açık hava basıncı
var 100 celsa kaynıyor O zaman ben
Dağlara Tepelere çıksam açık hava
basıncı azalsa sıvıyı daha küçük
sıcaklıklarda yüzden küçük sıcaklıklarda
kaynat yabilir miyim Aynen öyle hatta
uzaya çıksanız atmosfer basıncı
kalmayacağı için su anında Kaynar ve
buharlaşır Çünkü dışarıdan etki eden bu
dış basınç Yoksa bu baloncuğun
içerisindeki basınç kimle mücadele
edecek kimseyle Şuradaki sıvının kendi
basıncını ihmal edersem çok düşük
sıcaklıklarda bile kaynama olayını
görürsünüz everest'te gençler ki kendisi
yaklaşık 8 km 9 km yukarıdadır suyu 70
celsa
seviyesinde 100 olduğunu biliyoruz deniz
seviyesinden aşağıya inersek mesela Lut
Gölü dediğimiz İsrail taraflarında bir
göl olması lazım Ölü Deniz diye de
bilinir deniz seviyesinden 400 metre
daha aşağıda suyun kaynama sıcaklığı
101.4 cur Deniz seviyesin aşağı inersen
açık hava basıncı artar Bunun da bir
videosunu izleyelim açık hava basıncında
da benzer bir deney ortamı konuşmuştuk
burada bir vakum makinesi var buradaki
motor Şuradaki açık hava basıncını
alabiliyor bir fanus koyduğumuzda Şu an
bir çay bardağında suyumuz var ve
yaklaşık 18 celsus derece sıcaklığa
sahip termometre bunu gösteriyor veriyor
bu 18 celsius luk suyu kaynatabiliriz
Normalde 100'e çıkartmamız lazım ama
etrafındaki basıncı değiştirirsek bu
mümkündür bakın motoru çalıştırdık bu
fanusun içerisindeki havayı vakumluyor
yani burada açık hava basıncından çok
daha küçük bir basınç ortamı
oluşturuyoruz ve suyu ısıtmadığı halde
ona bir enerji vermediğimiz halde sırf
etrafındaki bu kaynamayı zorlaştıran
basıncı azalttığımızda
Çünkü etrafındaki basınç çok azaldı ve
şu an fokur fokur kaynadı görüyorsunuz
şu an bu suyun sıcaklığı hala 18 derece
yani kaynayan suyla yüzünüzü yıkasan
kendinize gelirsiniz o kadar soğuk su şu
an bu su şu an kaynıyor motoru durdurup
tekrar vanayı açarsak açık hava basıncı
içeriye girerse anında kaynama durur
Çünkü o devasa açık hava basıncı tekrar
geldi artık tekrar 100 Derece
çıkartmamız gerekecek mecburen kaynama
durdu suyu ölçüyoruz acaba 100 müymüş
Çünkü o kadar da kaynadı bakıyoruz
kaçmış hala 18 civarlarında Hatta daha
da azalmış neden azaldığını suyu
kaynatarak dondurabilir miyiz diye bir
şort çekmiştim on onu da orada
anlatmıştım oradan dinleyebilirsiniz bu
dersimiz bu kadardı takıldıkları alta
yazın Kendinize iyi bakın
[Müzik]
görüşürüz